getting knifed in cs go is a pretty rare
thing so when we saw a player get knifed
not once not twice but five times at the
ready-up cs go invitational people
started to get a little suspicious with
a hundred thousand dollars on the line
there were accusations that two players
on opposing teams might have been
teaming to split the prize pool and face
it even issued a ruling on this
situation and it's not what we expected
let's dive in
[Music]
it's august that means it's nearly my
birthday but it also means evo is nearly
upon us and the score esports will be
hosting a co-stream of evo on our twitch
channel twitch.tv slash the score
esports this friday saturday and sunday
it's gonna be a really fun event and i'm
gonna get to meet people that i haven't
even met face to face yet like danny and
liz it's gonna be awesome so tune in
don't miss it okay so the full name of
the event that we're talking about today
is the sony endzone 100 000
ready up cs go invitational and it was
organized by twitch it features
streamers playing or casting csgo many
of whom are not people that you would
associate with tax shooters does rich
ever play csgo
no i uh
i've never played csgo and i'll probably
never play shooters on stream and the
reason for that is i like talking too
much and in shooters you really can't
just just talk you know but the weirdest
thing about this tournament is that the
winners weren't determined in the
typical way where you win enough maps to
win a series and then just repeat until
you've won the tournament instead they
track the participants individual kills
assists and knife kills
kind of a weird fit for a game that's
based entirely around teamwork but
that's what they went with if you've
ever played or even watched cs you're
probably not surprised that in this
format a knife kill was worth five times
as much as a regular kill because it's
generally much rarer but that caused an
issue because on one of the maps there
were a lot of knife kills and they
mostly involved two players on opposing
teams ultimately the question was raised
by others playing in the event were
these knife kills an attempt to trade
points cross team to answer that let's
first talk about those players
gale adelaide is predominantly an
overwatch streamer and there's no
question in my eyes he's definitely
cracked
on me
i'll carry
okay
he was signed to tsm at age 16 and that
contract just recently ended this past
february brian keffrey st pierre is
predominantly an overwatch streamer and
if that name sounds familiar it's
probably because you've seen his name
attached to some widowmaker highlights
do have a history of just being a duo in
overwatch and according to gail the
night before the tournament the two
tried to brush up on some cs
fundamentals and apparently went pretty
well um i did play one game last night
with kefri and i actually top fragged so
i think there's hope for me to perform
i guess we'll see anyways the two
players were on opposing teams on mirage
and a lot of knifing happened
another one out mid
oh he's trying to farm the nade points
given that this was an individual
tournament and the two players involved
in all of these knifing incidents had a
previous relationship it's fair to say
that people were pretty pissed when i
left i think he ran that i think
just knifed him i'm never playing b
again dude somebody please pick up bro
are you kidding my skills
i don't know
that's why i'm asking someone to take b
i don't want b i'm tired of him
well i
in total the map had five knife kills
that featured only kefri and gail a
tweet from jake lucky popularized the
accusations and kefri responded to the
clip and defended himself saying that he
didn't hear and just sucks his words not
mine kefri was removed from the
tournament but faceit later cleared his
name in terms of cheating and having
media the marketing agency involved
stated that the removal was because of
an increasingly hostile environment due
to the accusations on stream kefri
clarified that money is not a motivating
factor for him and that
he's so good at cheating that if he had
cheated we wouldn't know about it
okay
so the motive is that you thought i
wanted to split the cash with gayle 5050
25k 25k okay
there we go i want you to know
i'm literally wearing 14 grand right now
so i don't i don't need money
okay so now that that's been established
um
if i was gonna cheat
as a individual with a master's degree
in intelligent studies and analysis a
former fbi analyst
having worked literally for all of the
three-letter agencies four and a half
years active duty army
we'll skip the part where you know i'm
the biggest advocate for a proper
anti-cheat and literally crucify all the
cheaters in overwatch we'll skip all
that if i wanted to cheat you would
never know
you would never know
i would never get caught
so i suppose the question now is were
they cheating like was this a conscious
attempt to feed points to a friend which
is basically what all of the accusations
go on to state unfortunately without
evidence we can't have a definitive
answer it's possible that both players
decided to feed each other kills before
the event it's possible they each had
each other's streams open since both
were streaming the event so they knew
where they were to meet up but we don't
have any evidence that this definitely
happened we could look at the kills see
if there's anything suspicious if it
looks like they were set up
intentionally for example and that's
exactly what no cocoa puffs did
oh my god oh my god i don't like where
that's going all right but i hear one at
a and there's one match so i'm just
smoke man
yeah yeah oh yeah you got me mid
i got a goddamn pistol
look up you know he's there
[Music]
coming back
the issue here is that these players
aren't exactly cs pros and that was the
defense that kefri gave anyways we could
try to figure out what a pro player
might optimally do in certain scenarios
but that gets a lot fuzzier here because
though the tournament might have been an
entertaining idea it wasn't exactly
na'vi versus faze so when we see a clip
like this where a 1v1 lurk away from
both the bomb and the action happens
it might be suspicious yeah but you
can't apply the same criteria to people
who aren't pros without an admission
it's pretty unlikely that we'll ever
have a definitive answer on the subject
having said that because these
accusations were thrown out knife kills
for the rest of the weekend started to
be viewed with kind of a suspicious lens
all right
go plant
[Music]
behind behind
oh
damn
[Music]
wow that's crazy
to his credit kefri did kind of admit
that trying to convince people he wasn't
cheating was an uphill battle and i
think that's some good self-awareness on
the other hand he also lobbed some
teeming accusations of his own at nick
bunyan and tiffay
yeah throws the smoke
and looks off her monitor
and now she looks back at her
monitor i was just saying where's your
cat this is a ballering coach that's
like immortal yeah i can't do it i don't
know how to smoke lower out like your
spawn all right looked off her monitor
looked off her monitor uh
you need to throw it gives her back
without clearing it well it's all for
monitoring i think it's from here i need
to bounce down
oh i got a knife oh my god wait how'd
they get by you guys
how'd they get bite you guys says the
person who literally gave up mid in all
of the vision in every aspect again i
have no idea if these clips look
suspicious to you
then the kefri and gael cliffs that we
already reviewed well
i'll let you judge for yourself but i'd
be surprised if this exact issue the
potential for teaming wasn't at least
discussed as this tournament format was
being planned the fact that there was no
contingency in place when the
accusations started flying is a problem
because the end result was that a player
had to be removed from the tournament
and perhaps even more than that there
were doubts about the entire competitive
integrity of the event relying on the
honor system in this context was just a
bad move hell look at what happened to
ms kiss schooled game show overall this
rule set was kind of a mess
if you had no money on the line you had
the right personalities and everybody
was committed to kind of just
letting the metagame develop in the
server it could have been pretty
entertaining but with money on the line
and fans looking to see their streamer
bring home glory it just wasn't it as an
aside it is kind of funny that the
cheating accusations that we're talking
about today aren't the kind where you're
like outperforming the expectations but
rather you have two players who we know
are crack and they're being accused of
like not playing well enough maybe the
drama put more eyeballs on this event
than would have otherwise seen it but
for the fans who were curious about how
their favorite streamer skills would
translate to cs go
the whole thing was a massive l
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tech talk